[Music]
okay everybody I am so excited today
because I am joined by Kathy and Rachel
who star in My Best Friend's exorcism
which is out tomorrow on Prime video how
you guys doing today
we're good how are you great I'm doing
great I absolutely love this film I'm
excited for the big weekend for you guys
and everybody to see this now Kathy you
are theatrically trained as an actress
so for upcoming actors and actresses do
you think that is super important to
even have a shot at being in a film like
this one day
um you know I gotta say actually I think
right now uh entertainers are like cross
medium always and I think that's a
wonderful thing about first of all just
like social media like we're getting to
see people just film themselves at home
and they don't necessarily have to have
gone to like an acting school
um in order to to get onto one of these
sets that being said I am so happy that
I had my time in school and and I just
hope you know that other people are
lucky enough to if they have that like
urge that creative urge when they're
young to go and try and take a class and
in whatever way in whatever art form
you're interested in so I don't know I
yeah no I love that answer and it's it's
positive and yeah it's totally fair I
totally agree with you too like it's
constantly Crossing past all these
different acting areas too so Rachel
your character of Margaret gets to take
some fun Jabs at our friends a lot I
feel like she picks on people a bit here
is there a certain thrill you get to
doing that part like that
honestly
not at first I actually really didn't
like how rude I had to be to everyone
and I remember having conversations with
David like could she be a little kind to
her like me and Elsie were like can she
be nice to Abby like we just won't have
a moment so I think that the way that
Margaret is mean in this film
specifically wasn't as fun to play with
as like some mean girls have been in the
past but I think she was a realistic
representation of girls who are mean out
of pure insecurity you know we get to
see a lot of markets and security play
out through the film and so it's kind of
obvious where that hurt comes from and
why she chooses to hurt her friends but
I did have fun overall playing her but
jabbing at the girlies was definitely
not my favorite part no but that's a
great answer it shows how well that
character was written too that that's a
great explanation of why that happens
now Kathy there is a scene where you all
play a Ouija board in this film does
that kind of thing freak you out at all
do you have any superstitions are you
that type of person
um I am not uh super superstitious but I
could very easily get scared in the dark
however
being around like the the crew and and
these girls the whole time made me like
at ease on set
um and I honestly just wanted to be
pranking them and like pretending that
they were Spirits amongst us
um but I I feel like I I felt okay
actually surprisingly because I'm not a
horror person
but I felt okay outside okay good yeah
because it comes off terrifying so it's
good it's good that you felt okay though
um now Rachel is there a more fun decade
to jump into than the 80s as an actress
honestly I'm gonna say no I was gonna
contest 90s I really do love the essence
of 90s film but 80s is more fun 90s has
its own beautiful things about it I
think 90s music is really cool but 80s I
don't think there's anywhere more fun to
go as far as costuming hair makeup music
energy I definitely think that we were
very set up for greatness being on this
film set in the 80s yeah and you guys
really delivered in that Vibe of the 80s
so Props to you guys it was really fun
to watch
um now it's 15 years of it Kathy it's
awesome that you voiced golden glider on
a hit show like Harley Quinn was that
really cool for you what was that
experience like are you excited about
more golden glider things
um yeah I love I love voice over just
because again kind of like in the way
that I got to be so big and and our set
was like so big and colorful and and had
those 80s Vibes like you know there's
literally no limits to the stories that
you can tell with animation and so
getting to play a a super villain uh was
pretty cool it was pretty fun
um because I don't necessarily know that
Kathy uh and you know my the way I
present to the world would read that way
and so it was it's always exciting when
I get to do a fun character like that
um and yeah like it's another story
about like women and their relationships
and and I feel like uh I don't know I'm
just proud of all the products that I've
gotten to be on very long yeah no it's
awesome man it's awesome that you did
such a cool product and you do a great
job on it and now before I let you guys
go Rachel I read that you are currently
developing a series of your own can you
give us any more info on that or a
little tease yes so I wrote a web series
and so that's currently in the editing
process right now I'm really big on like
wanting to create my own stuff to store
in I really like World building so
getting to create that world it is
coming soon we are editing it right now
and in the process of trying to get some
other things going so all things can
come into fruition but yeah thank you
for bringing that up so oh in the
process no that's exciting and it's good
to hear you're smart about it and
creating your own path too is always a
brilliant way to go uh but everybody
watch Kathy and Rachel kill it here in
my best friend's exorcism which is out
tomorrow in Prime video watch and tell
your friends about it enjoy it for the
spooky season thank you so much Kathy
and Rachel for joining me and we'll talk
to you in the future one day
thank you thank you we'll watch we'll
have a watch party and then yeah hell
yeah